Today I'm going to go pollen yeah wh
yeah
Another word study today is number 5
If you pick a little bit, happiness will
arrive.
If you
have that many agreements, you
can read more complicated books, you can read more complicated books, you
can understand daily programs
[music], you
can talk more broadly, and you can talk like an adult.
It's important to increase it.
Today I want to talk about my target
day. There are basically two ways to increase that consensus.
By doing that, your brain will gradually widen and
you will be able to become familiar with various breads
.
The process is more important than the above,
but another method is to study this word from a table of words while sitting in a
chair.
The recovery system is kind of like that.
The Space Crap Tissue System
is probably the most well-known method of memorization, but I prepare
it and never use it.
First of all, I'd like to do a little bit of preparatory work for
the past three months. It's an Arabic challenge for the three months of September, October, and November.
I want to take it to the depopulation of the words I know,
by carrying the fire department on my back
.  The number
is 2,000 yen.
Well, even now, it's not that hot to process.
In March 2003, I wondered how I would be able to achieve shipping costs of 500 nurses a month
, which would be difficult, but that's my goal.
It's boring,
I want to hear interesting pointcasts about politics in the Middle East.
If you look at it again, it's like that,
little by little, you'll touch on words little by little, and you'll
be able to wrap it up.  Okay, well, it
's almost almost Wakamoto-
setsu.
Only those words, so-called words, are reviewed.
There are
50,000 words, and I memorize 50,000 words every day. It's Flash Cardian Girls 6
, but while I'm reading it, I'm gradually
getting
tired of it.  I'm not interested at all because I'm waiting for only those words that can be said in the main text, and I
'm not interested at all in the situation of squirrels with two types of places
.
When I say "I understand" and "I remember that"
Every day
, I look at the top of the list of words that I can almost understand,
and I do things like I already know about 100 of
them.  So that 100 isn't 100 of the pure net, and
depending on the
past, 80 volumes would be 90, but as you do that,
the number of words you know will increase
.
The
number of words I know broadly is increasing more and more The number of
useless words is actually decreasing
So it's not that I'm giving away just with statistics It's words that I know what I actually read, hear and
feel
Of course
, I've heard that they're going to focus on politics and economics,
so
India, where the so-called consensus on that is coming out, is a bit expensive,
but in any field.  The frequency of occurrence of that word will decrease.The
difference will
be relatively quick, so I think it's more effective to concentrate on reviewing only those things that are somewhat familiar.Well,
that's
profitable.  Today's explanation may be difficult for those who are unfamiliar with
it, but for the time being, I'm going to do that
until the end of this November, until the end of
this month
, and I'm working toward that goal by saying that I'll be using Niman words in Arabic as well.
I am doing my best